monsieur merci de nous parler pendant
quelques minutes on sait que vous êtes
assez occupé avec cette conférence le
plaisir même bientôt tous les leaders
ont parlé ce matin de l'urgence d'agir
pour les changements climatiques lis pas
trop tard encore a dit monsieur obama
et pourtant le canada arrive à cette
conférence avec les mêmes cibles que le
gouvernement précédent
quand est ce que le canada va pouvoir
présenter un plan avec des cibles plus
ambitieuses de les deux moulins vieille
peau vous avez dit des cibles et un clan
le canada une cible qui pas si facile à
atteindre qu'on croit réduire de presque
du tiers nos émissions d'ici 2030 alors
que on est pas et continue à croître en
ce moment au canada
c'est une cible exigeante mais vous avez
parlé d'un plan on avait une si vive
émotion après vous n'avez pas de plan
par monsieur trudeau amène un plein les
provinces ont donné des objectifs
extrêmement exigeant elles atteindront
difficilement leurs objectifs sans
leadership vient du fédéral partenariat
en tout cas qui vient du fédéral mais
c'est ce que nous allons offrir leur
cible monsieur trudeau a dit d'entre
dans trois mois on va rencontrer les
provinces on va s'asseoir et on va
discuter mais alors on se donne un
échéancier de combien de temps un an
deux ans trois ans si on peut l'obtenir
en 90 jours un niveau que l'ambiance est
très heureuse et ça l'objectif
mais les négociations fédérales
provinciales on sait ce que c'est la
chose importante c'est qu'on doit agir
tout de suite on part attendre d'avoir
tout ficelé et donc vous allez voir que
dit ce que ça veut dire agir tout de
suite fait par exemple
on aura bientôt un discours du trône
vous verrez dans le discours du trône je
peux pas annoncé avant sera mais vous
avez que relire notre programme et il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'il faudra qu'on
lance tout de suite il faudra qu'on
lance le programme d'infrastructure
verte
le déploiement des énergies vertes du
tout les maîtres les mesures qui vont
permettre de réduire les émissions à un
fonds pour le climat qui va permettre
aux provinces d'avoir du financement
lorsque nous faisons des projets des
réductions de gaz à effet de serre se
sera pas un transfert aux provinces
avaient montré nous un projet où il ya
des réductions et on amènera du
financement fédéral
alors tous à financer sa très vite si on
veut commencer à agir pour réduire nos
émissions cessé de les voir croître et
s'acheminer vers l'objectif commun qu'on
se sera fixée
quel rôle le canada pourrait jouer parce
qu'on entend dire que peut-être il
pourrait faire partie de ce comité assez
restreint de pays qui négocie vers la
fin et qui est justement à trouver un
consensus à trouver un compromis
on peut être sûr qu'ils auraient des
canadiens parce que les canadiens sont
très forts et l'onu ils ont des
responsabilités importantes et nous
madame mais kana il sera aussi parce
qu'elle est là d'excellentes relations
avec toute l'organisation française mme
avec monsieur fabius et les déclarations
que nous avons faites ont rassuré tout
le monde
on s'est dit voilà les cas un dire m'ont
aidé on peut compter sur eux ce qui est
un changement comme on assure claire
leurent précédent tout à fait c'est le
jour et la nuit
mais en plus on est membre de tous les
forums quand vous avez fait la paix
qu'est commonwealth n'est pas beaucoup
de pays qui vous échappe
quant aux grands cantons de l'est
relation très étroite avec l'union
européenne
on est un des rares pays et en plus on
parle français en parlent anglais
un des rares pays qui a ses ouvertures
partout
ce qui va nous permettre d'agir de façon
très efficace
alors donc d'après vous les chances de
succès vous les voyez comment je vois
c'est que contient d'y arriver
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
quand j'ai l'honneur de présider la
conférence sur les changements
climatiques de 2005 à moriat donc coop
11 alors que maintenant le docteur cecop
21 mai vous en rappellerez à l'époque
léonid et on a réussi à avoir une
entente ce qui était très difficile
c'est qu'à l'époque les pays anticiper
les problèmes ne le vivais pas encore
alors qu'aujourd'hui les récentes de
plein fouet
vive la difficulté les changements
climatiques ce qui les amène à un
sentiment d'urgence d'eau jansky qui
prêtent à l'action c'est un peu dommage
qu'il faille que le puits soit vide pour
comment ce qu'on pense à réaliser la
valeur de l'eau c'est le problème qui
circulent ici mais c'est comme ça qu'on
a laissé les êtres humains sont parfois
il faut que l'on soit face aux problèmes
pour commencer à agir et c'est ce qui
arrive maintenant il est minuit moins
une plus on attend tout ça va être
difficile d'éviter un réchauffement
donc la 2° celsius faut vraiment gervais
est vrai que paris soit 1 m
ce pari sera pas la solution il faut que
ce soit une étape très importante dans
la lutte aux changements climatiques
on souhaite une bonne conférence merci
monsieur dion merci madame diallo